we are back and our next guest is a
Powerhouse in the world of True Crime
her podcast crime junkie gets more than
30 million downloads a
month let that sink in that's insane
it's one of many podcasts in her growing
media Empire which will soon include her
very own Serious Channel let's welcome
Ashley flowers
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
so we little known fact literally were
together yesterday cuz we are Channel
buddies yes yes we're Channel buddies we
both have a serious Channel now yeah old
friends now yes so crime junkies the
podcast when did you feel like it like
blew up when did you know that happened
oh my goodness so uh I I I intended to
make just like the small local thing and
at the oneye anniversary I'm like in
love with New Year's Eve like it is my
Christmas and so I was like let's do a
New Year's Eve party for Crime junkies
and you know we can have some fans come
it'll be great we'll celebrate you know
having a year of the podcast under our
belt yeah and all of a sudden like
people from like California and Georgia
were like buying tickets to this thing
and flying into Indiana in on New Year's
Eve and I was like which does not happen
I don't feel it's not a destination it's
not it's not Vegas you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah um so I was just like
wow this thing might be bigger than I
thought it was going to be yeah and at
the party that night we got uh told that
Rolling Stone named us one of the top
five True Crime podcast so it's like
everything at once that was the moment
where I was like oh my gosh this is big
oh my gosh top five I say you're the top
so how did you get into True Crime I so
my mom was like the OG crime junkie her
mom before her so when growing up like
it was Nancy Drew and then Agatha
Christie like all those good F love CHR
same and so at some point though
you know I I realized that they're like
real cases and I would say it was when
um the Jean banet case happened because
me and my young to remember that yeah
yeah me and my best friend Britt who I
do the show with we've been we have the
same birthday best friend since we were
like born yeah and we were like tabloid
height when that happened yeah I was
going to say yeah we were young and and
really I was almost I was maybe just a
year or two younger than her and that
was the first time where it was it was
literally put in my face that not only
do these real things happen but they
happened to someone my age someone like
me and does that terrify you that seems
terrifying it pro pro probably should
have I mean it was scary I definitely
remember being scared yeah um I
obviously didn't like go research it and
like tell people about the case but it
was it was what got me interested and as
was I got older and older just started
looking up more cases and wanting to
talk about them and wanting to figure
out like where's my place in all of this
like what can I do because I felt so
moved by the cases yeah so you you like
you want to solve cases this is a big
thing that you're actually a part of
actually you and your fans yeah I wanted
to be a detective nobody's giving me a
badge so I had to go about it a
different way nobody's giving me a badge
I'm trying I'm GNA get you your own
badge that's going to happen for
Christmas no that's incredible so
explain the nonprofit it's called season
of Justice yeah so you know when we
started the podcast for me it was all
about you know if I'm taking and taking
even when I was a consumer if I'm going
to be like consuming this voraciously
like crime junkies do like I can't stop
what can I do to actually like make a
difference and so it started you know
with volunteering I I volunteered with
my local Crime Stoppers it started with
donating uh then I got to the point as
the podcast was getting bigger at the
same time we were getting new
investigative genealogy which was
something that nobody knew was possible
nobody had budgeted for and what I kept
hearing over and over again from law
enforcement agencies and from families
is like the only thing standing in the
way of this case getting solved is money
and I was like I'll write you a check
and they were like we don't want a check
from a media company thank you very much
oh they're not allowed to like it gets
muddy and so I was like okay so we we
went through all the work to set up a
separate entity to fund this testing so
the it's been in business or you know
the nonprofit's been established since
2020 we've solved nine cold cases 11
Jane and John do have got their name
like you're not just talking about it
you're actually helping people it's
really cool I want to talk to you about
it's adessa Texas that's where this two
fans like listeners listening and then
they ended up being involved with this
case in Odessa right right so wait
explain to everybody okay so there was
this case from back in the ' 80s in
Odessa Texas where this priest was
murdered and they initially thought that
this the the last guy who was with him
they thought that he was responsible
couldn't really prove it he ended up
confessing we know so much more about
false confessions now and so he was
imprisoned and the wild part is he was
imprisoned even though he had receipts
he had a speeding ticket an actual
government document proving that he was
250 mil away when the crime happened he
spent 20 years in prison another 20 on
parole as a convicted murderer and we
you know we tell this story being like
you know it's it's so clear to anyone
who looks at it now that that it
couldn't have been him but it was
thought for a long time that nothing
could be done because a lot of the
physical evidence that could potentially
you know with new technology prove that
it was someone else had been lost
everyone thought it was gone destroyed
who knows yeah so we tell this story and
we get this email from these two
listeners out of nowhere and they're
like hey we heard it and we just happen
to be going to visit our dad who by the
way is the chief of police in Odessa
Texas and we tell him about this because
you know we'd never even heard of it how
can we not know about this what a small
world yeah does he know about this of of
course he doesn't he wasn't there when
it happened he's you know got his
workload so they get they tell him he
goes and has his team just take a look
around see what you can find they find
the missing evidence wow and so all that
many years later it's that many years
later they found an old fingerprint card
from the crime scene which basically
proved that it wasn't James ros' Prince
that were there the the prince got
matched to other people and this chief
of police I mean like my hat off to him
doing the right thing like no matter if
it's hard no matter what it means he got
the Innocence Project of Texas involved
to help James like get this through the
system and on October 4th 20123 he was
fully
exonerated which is like I don't even
know it's such an amazing thing but like
what does that mean for such loss in
someone's life you know what I'm saying
it was a long time right and and people
think about oh he was on Parole you
can't get certain jobs you you can't
vote you can't people look at you
differently even sometimes you know but
now that he's exonerated I mean not only
does he get his his name back his
dignity back but now he's eligible to be
compensated by the state of Texas who
wrongfully imprisoned him wow okay
Ashley has never talked to or met this
couple so we invited them to join us
today and they're here so everybody
let's say hi to Harley and
Michael
[Applause]
God oh they didn't
Hello nice to see you I love this green
you're beautiful hi nice to see you
never SE y have
SE oh my gosh so I this is the craziest
story to me so Harley so Michael how how
does it feel to be a part of something
like that that you exonerated someone
that was so just the Injustice of that
you know like and you're a part of like
that freeing of that information it it
feels amazing I mean whenever we uh
brought this case to Michael's Dad we
really didn't think that anything would
come of it we were so excited when we
heard the news that he was going to be
exonerated um we sent an email and a DM
to Crime junkie we're like y'all did
this like I mean your podcast did this
like there was no we told the story you
like I had no way of contacting the
chief of police or getting him to listen
to me at all okay has anybody ever met
James no never met him um we tried to
make it down to one of his uh prel
preliminary hearings yeah um but we
weren't able to make it so we're just if
he comes out next I'm going to pass
out well we did reach out to him and he
has a message for all of you so watch
this I just like to say thank you for
supporting me in my fight for justice
it's been a long journey indeed but it's
finally come through that conclusion
where Justice is finally going to
Prevail and
and supporters like you who believe in
my innocence
and have advocated Justice on my behalf
I thank you very very
much I I
cannot watch him or listen to him and
not think oh my God so much life was
stolen you know what I'm saying and you
are complete stranger to this human like
you know what I'm saying like complete
strangers and you ended up helping it's
such a beautiful thing but also like
what does that make you feel like
hearing that I'm just like overcome with
emotion I mean I and I think the truth
of the matter is like I think the whole
world would be a better place if we
stopped acting like we're like we're
strangers like we're not actually very
good point yeah yeah it's an incredible
thing what you'all have done so thank
you so much for
listening and thank you so much for
acting but thank you for acting on it
not everybody does that and it's it's
amazing you can listen to new episodes
join the other 30 million people and
listen to new episodes of crime junkie
every Monday wherever you get your
[Music]
[Applause]
podcast thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home